when I'm running backwards it almost
feels like I'm flying because it's such
a different visual perspective seeing
how far I've gone as opposed to how far
I need to go when you're going backwards
you can really just take a step back
literally and enjoy what you're doing hi
I'm Aaron Yoder I'm a backwards runner I
have the world record for the fastest
mile ran backwards my fastest backwards
mile time is 5 minutes and 54 seconds
I've been running forward for over 20
years I started running competitively
when I was in elementary school and then
ran on scholarship during my early 20s
I ran so much that I sustained a knee
injury my doctor told me to stop running
and I really didn't want to stop so I
knew I had to make some sort of change
[Music]
retro running or backwards running is
where you're literally just running in
Reverse and there's no impact on my knee
I run backwards everywhere I run
backwards on the treadmill I run
backwards on the track and also out on
country roads backwards running feels
great on my knee I don't feel anything
which is reason why I really enjoy it
[Music]
when I'm coaching my track team I
occasionally have them run backwards as
to enhance and diversify their training
workouts
onward and upward good job way to go
good warm-up there there's more
backwards runners out there than one
would think
there are hundreds if not thousands of
people that decide to run in Reverse the
last World Championships there were over
20 countries represented in close to 200
athletes backwards running has allowed
me to see things in a little bit
different perspective in a world where
everyone goes forward and I'm going
backwards it's really allowed me to just
get back to competing against myself and
not be so concerned what other people
are doing it found great gratification
in the fact that I'm just competing
against my own shadow
[Music]
you